okay I hate that I have to do this today
and I was hoping Monday Tuesday that I
wouldn't have to but I have to okay
YouTube ad pocalypse
2 point 2.0 might be starting now if
you're wondering 2.0 what was 1.0 almost
2 years ago to the day March 31st 2017 a
very very dark day in David Pakman show
history and in youtube history ad
pocalypse 1.0 started and what triggered
it was an ad for coca-cola appeared on a
racist ad a racist video on YouTube that
had about 800 views advertisers flipped
out saying if YouTube can't make sure
our ads don't show up on racist content
we're pulling our money out of YouTube
some actually did and as a result
YouTube drastically overreacted cut
almost all ads to news in politics
channels like the David Pakman show
and overnight we lost ninety-nine
percent of the revenue on our YouTube
channel revenue that we had come to rely
upon disaster now we had a slow recovery
over time we had many more D
monetization 's and still do but our
channel continued to grow
so our YouTube channel still to this day
makes less money than it did before ad
pocalypse but we had three hundred and
fifty thousand subscribers when at
apocalypse 1.0 hit we now have six
hundred and twenty thousand so it's been
we've worked our asses off to grow the
channel just to close the gap in revenue
that resulted from ad pocalypse 1.0 but
we thought things had stabilized until
this week this week we have started to
see what some are calling a soft news
and politics D monetization others are
straight-up calling it at apocalypse 2.0
this is happening instead of at the
channel level like we saw two years ago
it's happening at the video level and
I'll explain to you with examples how
this is happening we put out our video
for example commenting on Monday on the
Candace Owens Dave Rubin interview
Candace Owens interviewed Dave Rubin we
commented on that energy
that video was marked demonetised now
there's nothing in that video that is
not FCC friendly there's nothing in the
video that's not brand safe it's me
talking about an interview with simple
basic uncontroversial language the video
published Monday afternoon and was
instantly demonetised now I contact
YouTube YouTube says David no problem
just appeal the decision and a real
person will review it which we do but
the review process can take anywhere
from two to seven days the first 48
hours of a videos life are the most
important because that's when a majority
of the views are happening and case in
point 48 hours after we published the
video I get an email from YouTube saying
hey great David great news
monetization has been turned back on
except the first 48 hours have elapsed
and we've earned no money on that video
next example a video titled Trump
suddenly against releasing the Moller
report this is a video from yesterday's
show where we talked about the legal
comings and goings of Donald Trump and
Robert Muller and William Barr lots of
legalese and discussions of what is and
isn't and William bars four-page letter
it's not gory it's not racy it's not
sexual or outrageous or off of brand
safety but the video was at least
initially marked as possibly
inappropriate for some u're some viewers
on the basis of their age and it would
pop up something you had to click on and
acknowledge that even though this might
be inappropriate for some users you want
to watch it anyway this isn't d
monetization but these age limited
videos are disadvantaged in the
algorithm they get fewer views and we
get screwed again with a video that
quite frankly has no basis whatsoever
for being marked as for mature audiences
only or whatever phrase you want to
apply to it example number three we did
a video on Monday about Jordan Peterson
Peterson spoke at Liberty University on
a panel we commented on it nothing
remotely
no bullying no mean pranks no swearing
no nudity nothing but as you can see
from the yellow dollar sign instead of
green in our video control panel which
were showing our video audience
it was demonetised we appeal it it takes
two days and the appeal comes back as
yes this cannot be monetized hi david
pakman show after manually reviewing
your video we've confirmed that it isn't
suitable for all advertisers as a result
it will continue to run limited or no
ads a video where I just talk about
whether Jordan Peterson is or isn't a
political figure it's video of him
sitting at Liberty University talking
not monetized this could be the new ad
pocalypse this could be ad pocalypse 2.0
so here's what I want to do um
I refuse to start picking topics for the
David Pakman show based on what's going
to monetize it's a disservice to you
it's not how I run the show it's not how
I've ever run the show plus at this
point who even knows what's going to be
monetized on the basis of this wacky
algorithm last time we were sort of slow
on the uptake when this happened and we
fell behind financially and had some
calamities as a result I'm asking for
you to help us not need the YouTube
revenue get a membership on our website
okay
the memberships are really cheap its
cheapest two bucks a month if you use
the right coupon code almost all of the
money comes to us there are platforms
out there that keep 5% of what you
contribute there are platforms out there
that keep 10% of what you contribute
YouTube super chats 30% goes to YouTube
when you begin a membership on our
website 2.9 percent pays for the credit
or debit card fee we get the rest okay
almost all the money comes to us go to
WWE at medCom there are memberships for
every budget any membership is great if
you pay 60 bucks for the year or 6 for
the month or whatever it all helps ok
you get the bonus show you get the other
perks and yours
supporting us but most importantly we do
not want to be even remotely considering
what is going to monetize on YouTube
when we consider what it is that we
should cover on the show we cover what I
think is worth covering and that's the
way we want to keep it we have two
discounts that are available I know that
six bucks a month or 60 for the year is
a lot of money for many people so let's
just drop the prices if you want us to
drop them the coupon code this is 20 20
will save you 40% off of any membership
$6 a month becomes 3 dollars and 60
cents a month $60 a year becomes $36 per
year this is 20 20 will work on any
membership and lastly if you want to get
a year membership for 25 bucks one
payment 25 bucks that's like two dollars
a month two dollars and eight cents a
month use the coupon code save 35 on the
$60 membership it will only work on the
$60 membership
on code save 35 it'll drop the $60
membership to just 25 bucks two dollars
and eight cents a month for hundreds of
hours of content that keeps us
independent so I'm asking for your
support we are extremely worried about
what may be ad pocalypse 2.0 incoming
and I will keep you updated as I did
throughout pocalypse 1.0 and hopefully
this is not going to be nearly as bad as
some of the red flags suggest it may be
getting okay let's take a quick break
next I will speak to Igor Volsky about
gun safety and much much more one of
today's david pakman show sponsors is
simple habit an app that provides a
massive library of really excellent 5
minute guided meditations they're
letting everybody in our audience use it
completely free for one week when you go
to simple habit comm slash Pakman we've
talked a lot on the program about the
growing scientific evidence pointing to
the benefits of meditation and what
really sets simple habit apart is the
variety of guided meditations that they
offer more than 2,000 made for many
different issues that you may be dealing
with if you need
help falling asleep if you have anxiety
that you're dealing with if you want to
be more productive during the day they
have meditation specifically tailored
for certain times of day like when
you're waking up or your commute to work
or when you've just gotten home from
work I'm a huge advocate of meditation
myself I've really enjoyed integrating
simple habit into my day and each
meditation takes just five minutes and
they're very easy to follow maybe you
want to feel more grounded before you
start your day at work or at school
maybe you want to keep your mind a
little more clear so that it's easier to
accomplish your goals or you just want a
calmer more peaceful experience
throughout your day simple habit can
help you get there it just won the 2018
Google Play award for best well-being
app it's available on Android iOS and
web browser and you can try it
completely free for a week check it out
go to simple habit comm slash Pakman
I've put a link down below underneath
the video